世界で一番幸せな場所なので帰ってきました
ロンドンに在住している高校生の女の子が言った言葉です
お年玉クリスマスプレゼントすべて我慢してでもクリスマスキャンプに連れてって
rise テックという場所をどんなプレゼントよりも欲しいと言ってくれる子がい
ます
学校で居場所がなく引きこもりだった子が
自信をつけて変わりました
と
お母さんから泣きながら感謝をされたこともあります
そんな中高生や保護者の方たちの反応や変化をみると
少しおこがましいのですが大事節句をつくってよかったっ
生まれてきて良かったなと心から思います
本当に幸せな瞬間です
私たちは中高生一人ひとりの可能性を最大限広げるために会社を作りました
プログラミングやデザインなど it の技術を教えているのは今の時代に彼らの可能
性を広げるために適切な手段であると思ったからです
教育プログラムに大作るにはある種哲学のような思想が大切です
ライスチェックは2011年にスタートした
しました
そこには多くの失敗もありながら試行錯誤しながら今日まで
プログラムを作り上げてきました
本日はライステックというプログラムを設計する上で私が大切にしている重要な要素と
そしてそこから生まれた発想を皆様にお伝えしたいと思います
これはキャンプという合宿型4の機能ですね
プログラムの教室の風景です
中学生や高校生がスマホアプリ
ゲーム映像編集などの最新のプログラミングやデザインの技術を学んでいます
xcode unity photoshop などプロが使うようなツールを学ぶの
が特徴です
中高生は数日間でツールを学び
自分たちの作りたい作品自由な作品を作っていきます
私たちには理想の教室があります
5日間のキャンプでは3日目日または4日目に見ることができる
ある光景があるのです
教室にふと目をやると
隣の子のパソコンですね覗きながら作品を見せ合う子がいます
ふと見ると
ヘッドホンをしながらですね集中している高黙々と作業をしている子がいます
そして椅子ではなく地べたに座って講菓子を食べながら開発をしている子たちがいます
みんな自由に楽しそうにそれぞれのスタイルで作品の開発に取り組んでいます
一見好バラバラに見えるのですが
心で全員がつながりあっているような不思議な一体感のある光景です
こういう理想の教室の状態になった最終日の作品発表は参加者全体で
クオリティ作品のクオリティがぐっと上がった
とても高いですね
個性に富んだ発表を見ることができます
rise テックに参加している生徒の作品をご紹介します
こう妄想チャットというですね iphone アプリがあるのですがこれはですね
ちょっと面白くて好きなキャラクターやアイドルなどにですね会話を事前に高設定し
ます
おはようとかというとですねオハヨーって帰ってくるというアイドルの
アプリですねアイドルとかを設定できますでこの妄想チャップ
チャットというのはですねその妄想のチャットができるユニークなアプリなんですが
なんとですね
app store の無料ストアランキングに総合4位でランクインしたこともあり
ます
他にはですねユニクロの t シャツデザインに入線されたり
市の pr 動画にで大賞を取ったりあとはオリジナルの line スタンプが今
50種類以上実際に販売されたりしています
最近活躍している子たちの傾向として
中高生だから評価されるというわけではなくて
作品自体がユニークだったりクオリティが高い
そういったところの評価がされているように思います
少しずつ it の活用できる中高生が増えてきて
it を支えること自体が評価ではなく何を作っているのかというのが評価のポイント
に変わってきたんだと思っています
そんな中世界でもプログラミング教育が活発な動きを見せ日本では2020年に小学校
でのプログラミング教育の必修化が控えています
ただ必修化にあたりプログラミングを学ぶこと自体が目的になっている傾向が多く
私たちは不安視しています
プログラミングやデザインなど it の技術はあくまでもツールであり
it 技術を活用して何を作るのかそして何をなすのかの方が重要だと私たちは考えて
いるからです
例えるとですねまぁ本来本来であれば
英語というのは世界中の方とコミュニケーションをとるために英語を学ぶと言うはずが
学校教育の中で英語がテストの為に勉強するという風に
手段の目的化されてしまったことと似ています
なので今日私が英語でプレゼンテーションできないのはですね私のせいではないという
ことですね
さて何を作るかという子どもたちのクリエイティブな力を引き出すのは一朝一夕で
できることではありません
雷スティックではどうやってプログラムを設計しているのかっていうのをご紹介したい
と思います
まずライフイズテックでは講義形式ではなくワークショップ形式というもので
を行っています
良質なワークショップを行うためには目的を達成するための最適なデザインが必要です
理想の教室を作るためにはこのデザインが重要です
ワークショップデザインをする際にシンプルな原則があります
どこでどうやって誰が
ですシンプルなですねこの3つのクオリティ
この3つの要素のクオリティをグッと高めるだけで良質なワークショップを作ることが
できます
まず1つめのウェアどこでですがライフスティックでは大学のキャンパスや
そして it やゲームの企業さんのオフィスで行っています中高生にとって非日常で
あり将来自分がもしかしたら行くかもしれないなという場所で学ぶのは未来の自分を
想像させます
窓のないですね会議室で koa
まあ黙々とやってもです猫ワクワクしないですよね
さらに空間づくりにおいては参加者が五感で感じるということを大事にしなくてはいけ
ません
教室全体にはカラフルでですね色鮮やかで楽しそうだなというふうなものを視覚で伝え
てそして聴覚には自分の好きな高
bgm が流れると
参加者がストレスフリーな環境をつくるということが
そしてそのために細かく配慮するということがとても大切です
スタッフにはですねこんなこと言ってます机の向き
神戸変わるだけで中高生の人生が変わる
そんな風に言っています
時としてですねあまり広くないスペースでワークショップをやらなくてはいけない時が
あります
その際に高角度が5度違うだけで狭くなったりしてですねすごいストレスフルな環境を
作ってしまいます
ちょっとしたこのストレスというのがまあ大きな5日間あるとですね大きなストレスに
変わっていきます
そして特に初めて参加をした中高生というのは
ライフイズテックではなくパソコンでの作業自体が
を嫌いになってしまいますそうするとですね it への苦手意識が芽生えてしまって
a これからです
ね今後カレンの人生に大きく影響してしまうとそういうふうに思っているからです
ワークショップのデザインのポイントの二つ目はハウどうやってです
ライサチェックのキャンプのスケジュールをお見せします
黄色のこの時間がですね実際に学習および開発をする時間ですそしてもう一つ
青色のところ青色の時間は a子のか会参加者とのですね関係性をより良くするための
出し物だったりとか
レクリエーションの時間になります見ていただくと分かりま
菅初日や2日目は青い時間を長めに設定して
そして3日目ぐらいから最終日にかけてですね
この黄色の開発の時間を増やしています
楽しいから初めて後開発に集中していく
この緩急がですねとてもこの関係のあるバランスがとても重要だと考えています
また中高生にですね子供だましは通用しません
オープニングなどの演出名も高いクオリティーを目指しています
これはサマーキャンプのオープニング映像です
いきなりですねご着席してはい教科書を開いてくださいというよりもこんな映像を見せ
てですね
開始したほうがワクワク何が始まるんだろうと言ってですねワクワクしますよね
なので僕たちはですねこういった細かな演出というのすごくこだわっています
そしてレクレーションは大人でも楽しめるようなかなり凝った企画を実施しています
最後に3つ目のふー誰がです雷節句では
後6名のチームで学ぶのですがチームに1人メンターと言われている大学生のスタッフ
が教えています
そして前大学生電ある理由としては対話による学びというものを重視しているからです
中高生にとって大学生というのはですね少し未来の姿
気軽にこう質問やアドバイスをに乗ってもらったりすることで技術力だけではなくて
自分たちのですね
進路も見えてくるんですよね
メンターはこうかなり高い能力を求められます
技術力だけではなくて例えばチームを率いるリーダーシップ
あとはですね個性を引き出すファシリテーション力この5日間を楽しませなきゃいけ
ないので楽しませるためのコミュニケーション力そして最終日までに作品を持っていく
マネージメント力です
pr
実はですね昔あの僕たちはメンターごとにそれをお任せしていて特に校研修プログラム
なくてですね
でかなり後属人的になってしまいましたそうするとですね面白いことにメンターによっ
てこの山化している中高生のアウトプットとかですね成長がこう
まったく驚くほど差があったんですね
を誰がというのはワークショップにおいてワークショップのデザインによってとっても
一番重要なことです
だからこそ良いメンターというの僕らはすごく分研究をしてそしてし工作をしながら
100時間の研修プログラムリーダーズというのを作りました
今なお進化し続けるこのプログラムはですね
初心者の大学生を優秀なメンターに育てることができます
例えば現在ですね今全国に500名弱メンターというのが所属しているんですが
特にですね経験値の高いメンターというのは本当にびっくりするが優秀で
例えばですね it のコンテストだったりとか本当に様々な分野で活躍しているも
スーパー大学生 a たちばかりなんですね
やっぱりそういう彼らが中高生を導くというのはとても贅沢なことなんじゃないかなと
僕たちは思っています
もう一つですねさらにワークショップのデザインをする上で重要な予感点があります
それはですねコミュニティですでちょっと今からですね皆さんにちょっとだけやって
いただきたいことがありますごく簡単なことなんですがちょっとですね片手を上げて
いただいて
両隣の方もしくは近くの方とですね
ハイタッチをしていただきたいんですハイファイブ
ねハイタッチってその時にルールが一つだけあります相手の目を見て笑顔でお願いし
ますじゃあどうぞやって下さいお願いします
ありがとうございますありがとうございますえーまぁすごくですね簡単なことをした
だけなんですけどなんかちょっと隣の方となくなりましたよね
で一瞬ですねこうワットこう会場全体で盛り上がりのようなものがですねできました
でこれが錬成こんな状態がターンのしばらく続くとこれはですね解除前との一体感と
いうものにつながっていきま
see
僕は今どんなことをしたのかというのですねちょっとだけ解説をさせていただきます
例えばこのテッドのこのプレゼンテーション僕のプレゼンテーションの
この空間をですねひとつのコミュニティとしてとらえたときに今
スピーカーオーディエンスそして他のオーディエンスの大きく3要素に分解したとし
ます
でこのハイタッチをする前はですね僕が私がですね皆さん有益な情報を伝えようという
ふうにですね頑張って話をしてこういった繋がりを最初は作ることができました
そしてですね今最後にハイタッチをしたことでオーディエンス同志の皆さんがですね
こんなつながりを持ちました
コミュニティの要素のこのすべてがしっかりとつながりを持った瞬間に実は一体感と
いうのは生まれ始めるのです
学びの場こそですねこういった一体感がとても大切だと考えています
教室にいる全員に安心感そしてつながりを持てば
自由な発想と行動がですね自然発生的に生まれ
そして私たちが考える理想の教室となるのです
ですので我々のプログラムでは初日はこことここをつなげようと
そして2日目はこことここをつなげをどことどこをつなげるかというのはですね綿密に
まあ設計をしています考えて設計をしています
コミュニティのすべての要素がしっかりと繋がればさらにそしてですね太くなった瞬間
に熱狂に近いような一体感というのが
生まれますそしてそれが理想の教師とつながります
こういったプログラムですね設計する上で最近 lx あ
learning experience という発想を取り入れています
この lx learning experience というのは
体験学習という意味ではなくて私たちが独自に設定している概念です
lx learning experience は
この it 系のですねあしてとして it 系のプロダクトやサービスを設計する上
でユーザーが特定のサービスを使ったときに得られる経験や満足など全体を指すことが
これをですね
ux ユーザーエクスペリエンスと言ったりします
lx はですねいわばその ux の学びバージョンになります
学習における experience 体験そのもの全体を指しています
学びの場を提供する側がこの lx を意識しているかで大きく
学習者の体験は変わります学習というとですね
皆さんはこの地域知識や技術を得ている瞬間勉強している瞬間というのをこの学習と
いうふうにフォーカスしがちなんですが
しかしですね学習者は一つのプログラム
参加するだけで多くの経験をしています
その
すべてが学習であるということを捉えるそういう風に捉える必要があると思っています
ライスチェックのキャンプでは
あるを知らないフルーツティックのキャンプにある一人の参加者が参加をしたとします
そうするとですねどんな体験どんな経験をしているのでしょうか
少しだけ皆さんちょっと想像してみていただきたいと思います
朝5会場に到着をしますすごく抗不安で緊張しています
そしてメンターが笑顔で話しかけます
するとちょっとホッとします
そして凝ったオープニングをばーっと見てですね
なんかちょっとワクワクしますそのと後に今度はチームで自己紹介をします
でその後に開発をし始めます
その後パソコンが酵素の人は慣れてないんですねなのでちょっと苦労します
なんかやだなでお昼ご飯はですねこんなメンターとご飯を食べに行きます
でその時にですねたわいもない話をしたりとかそしてですね
大学の個性傘の裏事情みたいなを聞いたりしますでこうみんなで笑ったりします
お昼の後はですねレクリエーションをやります
そしてドキドキの内容でもうかなり面白かったなと興奮しました
そして開発に戻ります途中エラーでですね心が降りそうになります
それをですねメンターが励ましてくれます
そしてあーなんとか頑張っていけそうかなといって一日目が終わります
そして次の日そして次の日
さらにメンターはですねチームメートとの絆をます深めながら
そして開発にも慣れていきます
そして最後に作品を完成させます
そして最終日プレゼンテーションをします
お母さんとか見に来ています
緊張します
そしてなんとかチームのみんなのおかげでプレゼンテーションを成功させます
そして最後メンターやチームメートとの泣きながらこうお別れをします
5みんなにですねからもらった寄せ書きを見て帰りの電車
みます寂しいなと
そして家に帰ったらですね興奮してキャンプにあった出来事というのを家族に話し出し
ます
it で何か作るの楽しかったなと
また何かやってみたいなと
あそこで会った友達と会いたいなぁと
次までにもっと実力をつけておこうと
そして独学で it を学ぼうと決意します
すべてを学びと捉えプログラムを設計するかで学習者の成長や
可能性は大きく変わるのです
なので lx はテクニック論ではありません
教え方をこうすればいいよとかですねレクリエーションはこんなことをやればいいよと
いうことではなくて lx というのは
学び自体をマクロ的にとらえて丁寧かつ緻密にミクロ的に実践をしていく上でいてして
いくことで上質な
エクスペリエンスを目指そうとそういった発想になります
ああああああ
最後にみなさんにメッセージを
私は it を学ぶ場を作るという教育の活動に携わってきました
この教育というものですねもし広義的にとらえることができたなら
私たちの生活においていたるところにこの教育という活動は存在しています
家族に何かを教えること
部活の後輩を育てること
先生として指導すること会社で部下を育成することそして自分の子供を育てること
誰にとっても教育というのは切っても切れない存在です
そして教育という活動する前提には大切な相手がいます
教育というのはその大切な相手にあなたが思っている
知識や知恵や思いを伝える行為です
だからこそあなたの想いをしっかりと伝えるためには本日お話しした lx という
発想
これが役に立つんではないでしょうか
皆さんこれからも拘り続けるであろう教育というものを少しでも良い方向で捉え
あなたと教育でつながれる大切な誰かとの時間がより有益でより幸せになることを心
から願っていますありがとうございました選挙
ます